hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor i'm an entrepreneur
i've made millions of pounds investing
in property and right now
whenever i make a decision i'll always
say before i do anything
it's got to be ticking one of these
three boxes and i think most people
they do what they are told to do most
people
they get out of bed because their alarm
clock tells them they then drive
rush to work because their boss is going
to be they're going to be in trouble if
they don't
they then pick up the phone because
someone's ringing them and it's urgent
because if they don't answer
maybe they'll tick somebody off and
their whole life
they live their whole life trying to
please others
doing what other people are telling them
to do making sure they're out of trouble
and honestly that is not how rich
people act and if you're watching my
youtube channel you're probably a
property investor
or you're wanting to get into property
investment so here's what i'll say
okay if you've got no property deals
right now but you want to start making
money in property and you're thinking
deal sourcing rent to rent lease options
and you're wondering how to get started
here is the thing there's three things
every time you do something
it needs to be ticking one of these
three boxes number one you need to ask
yourself a question
and the question needs to be this number
one is am
i learning am i learning
i mean when i started out in property
most of the decisions i was doing most
of the thing i was just doing it for
experience
i was renting out people's rooms for
free i was
going to training conferences i was
reading books i was
i was deliberately using my time to just
try and learn
i just i just want to learn because i
know that the more i learn
the more ultimately i'm going to become
and the more i become the more i'm going
to impact people the more money i'm
going to have
the richer fuller life i'm going to have
so you've just got to learn more
i think it's really important so you
know if you're doing something rich
robert kiyosaki says this he says you
know don't trade your time for money
you know he says poor people or middle
class people they'll work for money
but actually when he started he was
working for knowledge
he was trading his time not for money
but he was trading his time for
knowledge and experience
so get around people that are succeeding
and say how can i help
how can i serve you what can i do for
free that's the first thing
am i learning second thing is you need
to ask this question
um i
earning am i earning what's this going
to make me
you know how much how much money am i
going to make from doing this and if
you're doing deal packaging you need to
be thinking
how much money is this going to make me
if you're doing rent to rent you've got
to look at the figures
you know rather than just thinking i
mean a free house doesn't necessarily
mean it's a good house
sometimes people are just desperate for
a deal or they're just desperate for
but it's like actually no am i earning
how much am i earning
okay so if i'm doing something i'm gonna
say am i learning no i'm not but am i
earning yeah i'm earning well okay
maybe it's not too bad am i earning i'm
not earning
i'm not getting paid am i learning okay
well yeah i'm learning lots that's okay
then and then there's a third one
and the third one is very simply am i
having fun am i having fun
okay am i learning am i earning am i
having fun that is
it if you're not earning what you want
to be earning doing something
if the pain is not there are you
learning
and if you're not learning and you're
not growing and experience from doing it
are you having fun if you're not having
fun if you're not do if these two things
are not happening if there's not least
one of these boxes with a big
fat tick next to it my advice would be
stop
doing it only do things when you're
earning learning
or and having fun what do you think
comment below your thoughts i look
forward to seeing you on the next video
you might enjoy this video by the way
this video this video is amazing so
check that video out it's just for you
also if you want to see my students i've
got a lot of students they're succeeding
in property as a direct result of my
training
check that out right there and please do
me a massive favor and subscribe as well
okay
so thanks so much i'll see you next time
peace